today i'm going to be showing you a day
in my life as an amazon intern
i've been working at amazon web services
in sydney for around seven months now
and last week i started a new role in
the professional services team
this internship is for three months over
the summer and because of covert
restrictions
i'd be mainly working from home but
slowly transitioning back into the
office for a few days a week
in this video i'll be showing you a day
in the office but i'll also be making
another video showing you what a day
working from home is like
so if you're interested in seeing it
please consider subscribing to stay
updated
every day i wake up at around seven
o'clock to get dressed
get ready and prepare for the day ahead
[Music]
on the days i go into the office i join
my sisters in the car on their way to
school
and get dropped off at the local train
station
[Music]
it's a 20-minute train ride to work and
on the way i either listen to some music
or read books on my kindle
today i'm reading a book called atomic
habits and it talks about how the
smallest changes in your routine can
develop into life-changing outcomes
[Music]
the good thing about the office is that
it's very close to the train station
so on rainy days like today i don't
really need to use an umbrella during
the commute
[Music]
when i go into the office the first
thing i do is get my temperature checked
and collect one of these wristbands
i usually work with around five or six
other interns in the office
and we decided to invest in some bread
to make sure we eat our breakfast every
day
how is it it's all right it's not bad
it's not bad i can see people eating it
but i wouldn't eat it again as an intern
my days are typically filled with
meetings
coffee chats working on projects and
some self-study so now i'm spending some
time preparing for an aws certification
exam i have coming up next week
studying for edible certifications isn't
really something that's mandatory for
interns but it's a really good way to
gain an understanding of technical aws
concepts and get some hands-on
experience
[Music]
at 12 o'clock i have a virtual catch-up
with an aws solutions architect
i typically try to schedule around two
to three calls each week with people
outside
my team and i find it to be a really
good way to learn about the different
roles and teams in the company
as well as get some useful career advice
from people from all sorts of
backgrounds
now it's time for lunch and today we're
heading to xanax square to
try out a new place called toasty smith
[Music]
after lunch we tune into a virtual
fireside chat with the amazon leader
as summer interns we get invited to a
lot of these online events and q and a
panels
so it's a really good way to hear from
some more senior people in the business
and ask any questions that we have
around three o'clock now and i'm taking
a break by getting a drink and chatting
with a few people in the kitchen
[Music]
what did you do today we went for a
good stroll a good stroll down darling
hour
but yeah for the next two hours i sit
down to do some work
and since it's the second week of my new
role i'm mainly going through some
training modules to get an understanding
of my intern project and learn more
about what the team does
after work we head to a dinner and
drinks event and get to know some
interns from other teams
and this basically wraps up my work day
now i head home spend some time with my
family help out with some chores
and get ready for bed
[Music]
if you enjoyed seeing a day in my life
as an amazon intern please give this
video a like and subscribe for more tech
and student advice videos
let me know in the comments below if you
have any questions bye for now